so Aloe Blacc who wrote and sang the
song wake me up he claims it was the
13th most dream song on pandora in 2014
more than 168 million streams in the
United States but that yielded only
twelve thousand three hundred fifty nine
dollars in Pandora royalties which works
out to nine thousandths of a cent per
stream or $90 for every million streams
is that accurate is that ballpark well I
came to the math of my head and I'm like
answer that I'm sure it's ballpark
correct but twelve thousand dollars if
that's anywhere near ballpark it just
doesn't sound fair at all I thought well
so one thing to remember too is people
talk about spins on radio a spin on a
broadcast station is a spin that goes
out to hundreds of thousands of people
if not more but before I answer let me
just put a little context but I think
it's really important because this topic
is obviously a heated topic and and I
think it suffers from a lot of
misperceptions so the first thing is so
pandora pays about half of its revenue
in royalties so about 1.2 billion today
we did 450 million last year the bulk of
that royalty goes to the performer a
much smaller portion goes to the
songwriter which is what that quote
refers to that ratio is not set by us
that's actually a subject of law that
predates Pandora that's an industry
question how should that money be
divided up the second thing is Pandora
is the highest paying form of radio so
we pay more than any other form of radio
and we pay not only the composer but the
performer broadcast radio which is a
much bigger industry does not pay the
performer anything at all and so really
the elephant in the room with this
conversation Ashley is why is it that
you've got this industry it's many many
times a size that does not pay
performers where we pay substantially I
think that's got to get worked out over
time so who should be paying I think all
streaming radio should pay both
composers and performers absolutely how
does that apply well it applies to every
business streaming online radio online
offline I mean those businesses should
be sharing their stake with artists
actually I think the the revenue coming
from Pandora's being
I think very fairly share with the
business do you think artists should be
paid more I mean you're an artist
yourself thing the way we're sharing it
is very equitable so Taylor Swift pull
her pulled her music off Spotify why
didn't Taylor Swift pull her music off
Pandora
well she can't actually so we're under a
compulsory license means artists can't
actually pull their music off of Pandora
and I think for her and a lot of our
artists what they're really responding
to is a lack of transparency so they see
and read about the economics of these
businesses and they don't see that
reflected in the royalty statement and
what happens in the middle there is a
black box and I think that's happening
more and more I think title was
triggered by that same thing so you have
to think people like Taylor and jay-z
have the best lawyers the best people
out there saying this is how you bring
it down well spotify is not making
enough money for you and i think it's
certainly true that some artists by
virtue of their popularity and scale
have the ability to I think command more
and and set the terms more that's not
true of the vast majority of artists